I'd rather be in person I'd rather you
know if we could be you know talking
about this stuff and then going out and
working on it the biggest thing you know
biggest difference right now is we're
all talking about it and then you know
we hang up the zoom call and I go chase
three kids and you know Danny goes and
does yoga in his underwear or whatever
and Kenny's catching balls from a jug
[Music]
you know it's just a matter of time
before team started putting up
sponsorship logos virtually behind these
players who are doing the zoom
conference calls smart move I'm
surprised it took so long I'd rather
look at what's actually behind Matthew
Stafford not the the big blue sheet with
the Lions logo and the sponsorship logo
but hey this is an opportunity to make a
little scratch and I suspect more and
more teams will do it but hey the bottom
line is guys are trying to get ready for
the season they're working out alone
eventually they'll find a way to work
out together and there's a lot of
pressure big cat on the Lions this year
Martha Ford the owner of the team made
it clear last season when she said GM
Bob Quinn and coach Matt Patricia are
coming back that she expects something
better this year than what she's gotten
and Stafford's injury last year had a
lot to do with the team's failures but
there's a lot of pressure on Stafford
there's a lot of pressure on the
coaching staff there's a lot of pressure
on the front office and they started off
fairly well last year they won some
games that pass lines teams would have
lost but you know my mindset with the
Lions organization given where they've
been pretty much my entire lifetime of
watching football they're gonna have to
prove it to me before I sign on oh
you're changing their tune for my famous
clip last fall when I said that you
could you could always sleep on the
Lions and never wake up and then you
took great umbrage to that calm that's
not what I said
that's not what I said my point is
they're gonna have to wake me up I am
going to sleep on them until they wake
me up but I will I will be happy I will
be ready I will be prepared for the
nudge on the shoulder to come when Matt
Patricia says wake up we're five and two
I'm not writing them off but I'm not
gonna buy into any hype or any
speculation that they're gonna be
halfway decent this year unless they are
the biggest story here I think
Matt Stafford's back injury because he's
one of the toughest guys in the NFL he's
you know he doesn't miss games he played
through a ton of different injuries so
the fact that he did miss a game and
missed a lot of games means that that
injury was very very significant and
what will be the lasting effect you know
he's on the wrong side of 30 a back
injury doesn't just go away it's not
something like a like a broken bone that
will eventually heal and you'll be a
hundred percent so that is the biggest
question mark with the liens going
forward because for them to be any type
of decent they need Matt Stafford to be
really really good and he was really
good at the beginning of last year
before he got that injury yeah you know
as Tony Romo got closer and closer to
the inevitable end of his career because
of back problems Troy Aikman said
repeatedly I didn't retire early because
of concussions I retired early because
of back issues so we need to watch that
with Matthew Stafford he's still fairly
young even though he's been around for a
long time how much longer we'll be in
Detroit and candy stay healthy this year
big questions for the Lions let's take a
break when we return troubling news
involving a Giants defensive back and a
Seahawks defensive back we'll get you up
to speed on that one for Oklahoma pot
walkers
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports